Kate Hudson adorably reveals what she's
getting her mom Wolsey Han for Mother's
Day in the new Garry Marshall flick
Mother's Day Kate Hudson plays Jessie a
woman who's not so close with her mom
just all this Mother's Day stuff and I
start thinking about how I haven't
talked to mom but in real life things
couldn't be more opposite the actress
and her mom Goldie Hawn are extremely
close Kate opened up to et on Thursday
at a screening of the film in New York
City where she revealed the special gift
she's getting her mom this year
a letter mom likes a set you know
something that meaningful things I'd
really do that all of us being together
I think makes all of us happy and what
makes us happy is Kate's stunning
fashion choices
thank you the 37 year old confirm she'll
attend next week's Met Ball chaired by
none other than Taylor Swift she's the
best girlfriend she great at that and as
for Kate's ensemble for the big event
well she teased it's gonna be epic
it's not subtle but but I'm excited I
actually don't know just yet I've got
two different